When I have to do a talk show.
When I have to do, um, your press of any
kind. I generally kind of loosen myself up a
little bit because I am like, I'm a by
nature, sort of a it takes me a minute.
I'm kind of a shy person and, and, um, uh,
you know, I try to.
Sort of get there.
Yeah. Normal conversation.
We're not here. This isn't hart to heart.
If you meet me outside, do you feel like
it's going to take you a second to talk to
me and get to wherever you got to get?
I mean.
Not in the same way.
Not the same way.
But that's the beauty of this because it's.
I'm embracing that.
Yeah. I'm I'm not embracing the.
Yeah, the other side.
So the only reason why I ask you that when
you say, yeah, it takes me a second, get
there, I'm talking to you.
Yeah. And there's a, there's a real calm.
There's like a, there's a calm, there's a
cool. I'm trying to look for it.
I'm trying to see if I see because I don't
want to f***ing press you and get you to
anxiety.
Like if you. No, no, no I by I'm by no means
anxious.
But that's my point I don't I don't see it.
So as you're talking.
No it's not, it's not I'm not a 24 over seven
anxiety ridden person.
I'm, I'm you know when when it appears is,
is. Uh, unpredictable, but, um, but it's
generally it's not debilitating, and I'm not
somebody who suffers from it to such a
degree that some people do where, you know,
you just you just can't function.
There's demand on you, your Seth MacFarlane,
you have now an entity, an enterprise, this
f***ing world of animation that you've
built. There's a lot of people that work for
you.
I'm not one of these producers who does a
little bit of everything.
Okay, so I'm either 100% in control of what
I'm working on. Okay.
Which at the moment is, is this Ted series
that we're doing for Peacock?
Okay. Um.
And that's my day, top to bottom.
So I'm either 100% invested or I'm 100%
trusting somebody that I trust to, um, to
handle another property, like family Guy,
American Dad.
Um, those shows right now are under the care
of the show runners. Okay, I, I offer
suggestions, but if I'm not there physically
running it, I don't feel like I have the
right to go in and and say, no, you got to
do this like I'm not there day to day.
They are. So it's like, you know what?
It's it's a blessing and a curse.
The buck stops with you.
Don't f*** it up. You know, I record the
voices for family Guy. I haven't been over
there in a number of years.
Okay? There are writers on the show that I
haven't met because I'm no longer in charge
of that show. I've entrusted it to people
that I trust.
So with the people that you've entrusted.
Yeah. All right. There's a reason for.
Right? You voiced several times.
You're 100% guy.
Um, with that being said, then.
Are your other successes underneath the
umbrella of you?
Do you feel that?
Do you feel that they've met your
expectations?
Like everything, it's nuanced.
Like everything on the planet.
It's nuanced, it's textured.
It's it's case by case.
You know, I look at something like American
Dad! And yeah, I do the voices of those
characters. But what that show is and what
it's become, um, I can't take I can't take,
you know, I can take credit for creating it,
but you create a show, and then the show
becomes something completely different.
Um, you know, Mike Barker and Matt Weitzman,
you know, who's currently running the show.
It's that's their success more than it is
mine.